what the heck was that that's a pretty
great thing I just watched yeah you sure
got some splainin to do Nikko well I'm
about to explain a whole lot because
this is the prison behind-the-scenes
yeah
so you guys are probably wondering what
this whole prison thing is about let us
tell you this all started back last year
after we've made frozen crossing
actually no way farther than that
this happened ten years ago when we
first started doing visual effects so
when we first got our start and visual
effects back in the day we started with
a program called LM DB made by some of
our friends in the UK they run a website
called FX home it's a great online
community for indie visual effects
artists is where we got our start in
fact if you go over there you can watch
many movies and salmon i goofing around
and we're like 15 years old and making
fools of ourselves before youtube so
they came to us and said hey guys frozen
crossing was really rad we want you guys
to help us with the new software and
make a sweet video with it what did we
do
we made prism we made the cost most
expensive big budget high production
value thing we could possibly dream up
we also help them with the software so
we'll talk more about how he did the
visual effects and its lair but first I
want to talk about the actual production
how he came to actually make this movie
yep our goal of this project was to make
it look like a real movie so there's a
lot of challenges ahead of us do
something like that a production like
prison was rather huge and actually it's
one of the biggest we've ever done in
our entire lives so far now there's a
lot of things that are not usually
required for you know normal YouTube
videos things like having to deal with
huge crews things like bringing scripts
pre-production equipment making our own
custom props masks things like that gear
dealing with you know just tons of
organization moving into something like
this we shot this whole thing in two
nights in downtown Los Angeles which is
kind of unfortunately expensive usually
when we go out and shoot a video out in
the street we just go out and do it and
our neighbors don't care we have like
three people out there
no one cares so this time we actually
had to go out and get permits and we
actually had to pay for our locations on
top of that we only in ten hours in each
location so I actually shot this entire
movie in two nights check this up one
mistake and the whole thing goes to hell
yeah how we doing boss Hey
sans going to take an order directing
I'm taking over trying to tell Sam to go
faster yeah we are we were pretty
exhausted when it's all done
yeah totally worth it even though prison
was a rather huge production for us we
still did a lot of the stuff just from
scratch with our bare hands like these
cool guns you see in the movie I put all
these together by myself check this out
- these masks / prism we had a friend
make some sketches for us based off of
some of our odd awkward descriptions and
Niko made a 3d model and then we cut it
out of a piece of foam and molded it oh
so for a piece like this the guys at FX
home actually gave us a budget to
actually get all the stuff we need so my
budget was this big no-no here is this n
okay Sam's on that side so for budget
was this big this is about how much we
spent on locations permits paying the
actors and the crew for the time helping
us all the people guns and casting guns
and costumes some hard drives and then
pretty much food to feed everyone and
that's it let's talk about some of the
effects that we did in this piece let's
believe it or not the vast majority of
effects in this we're actually pretty
simple is either compositing stock
footage doing some fancy particle stuff
or adding some lens flares haha the one
exception to this being the the laser
shots you can see why we're not the vast
majority of everything you see here can
entirely be done within the hit film
however for any type of post-production
process you will usually use more than
one program in this case we want some
funky 3d graphics and as always we call
upon our trusty friend 3dsmax give us
some cool elements that we could use so
after you get renders in a 3d program
you still need to composite them so
that's where hit film comes in there
alright cool effect number one plasma
rifle so for the plasma rifle effect
obviously it's very similar to a normal
muzzle flash or a normal rifle going off
except there's a couple key variations
in it the first is mostly in the actual
hits themselves normally for a bullet
hit you have a big cloud of smoke you
have some little chunks and Sandy breeze
but what I did here is I made a small
smoke poof that is made out of smaller
wisps and then I would take those wisps
and put it within the bullet hits to
make this like electrical kind of like
plasma effect
anything explodes from it and for the
muscle flashes I even use those same
files therefore the bullet hits and turn
them into muzzle flashes as well as you
can see here put a little ripple on that
call it a day so at this point we've
actually made a lot of our own stock
footage from various projects we've done
we now have bullet hits smoke puffs
muzzle flashes and imprison we got to
use it all for the film you know my
favorite effect was Sam know with the
lasers no teleportation I'll talk about
the lasers later but here teleporting
it's really really easy effect and what
makes it really effective is just having
a huge amount of particles it adds an
extra level of visual complexity that
just makes it feel really natural also
there's a little bit of frosting on top
of everything and that is a displacement
Ripple
boom make a black donut like the type
that you don't eat put that in there use
that as a displacement map done so very
similar to the teleporting effect was
the the Taser and the sparking effect at
the end when it's shooting out of the
mr. Blackwell's prism basically this is
another similar effect I was done with
the particle engine which is actually
pretty damn sweet I do a shot like this
basically set up a particle emitter on
the best to shoot out particles as well
as some stuff sent out lightning it's
basically just a lightning filter you
set your points a couple little particle
emitters from the lightnings hitting the
ground to south Sparks a little black
mark on the ground to show where the
lightning hit it it's really pretty
straightforward
somebody's players on his best so that
give the impression of the Lightning is
emitting light it's just a lot of basic
layers put together on top of each other
with a little bit of artistic flair and
stylization to really sell the piece how
to make the lasers how'd you make the
lasers so what we did is for the actual
effect is this is the this is one of the
very few effects that we had to go
outside of hit film fors um of course as
you guys are familiar with Ray Fire was
used for this to create all the little
fragments and stuff like that
however on top of that was just a layer
of composited smoke dust and pretty
average bullet hits and just having all
that at the scene just makes it all come
together
so anyways as you guys can see a whole
lot of cool stuff really nothing too
complicated just a whole lot of it and
really that kind of defines a piece like
this just a lot of hard work doing a lot
of just kind of normal things
so actually one really cool thing about
the sound for this piece is a friend of
ours named Rob crackle
the pronunciation okay what he did is he
watched our piece and was like guys have
I got some sounds for you I was just
working on uncharted three and I'm gonna
help you still I'm doing your sound for
this piece right now whether you like it
or not we're like alright blow hey to
check out these crazy sounds he made and
so that saved me a ton of time since I
didn't have to do it all myself again
we'll talk more about actual sound
design another video for you guys
because there's a whole lot of cool tips
and tricks that you can actually utilize
to make sound sound good alright guys
thanks for watching check back next week
because after we get some rest we're
gonna upload another behind-the-scenes
video that shows you some cool
behind-the-scenes footage of how we shot
this movie you see how we were directing
it you can see the people in costumes
who are having to move around this video
we are just showing you right now is
only the tip of it there's so many crazy
things that we did on set and you're
gonna love it so many crazy things it
was just like a dance party it was
literally a dance party and Niko lost
his heart on the dance floor never again
you